- [Mark] All right, Edgar.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Edgar] Originally Franklin, Virginia.
I've been out here since, I came out here
when I was five years old.
- [Mark] And, you grew
up in which neighborhood?
- I grew up here in
Watts, Nickerson Gardens.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
You had both parents as a kid or not?
- No, just my mother.
My dad is,
he was still in Franklin, Virginia.
Me, my mom, and my sister came out here
and I was just, just me and my sister.
- [Mark] And how would you
describe your childhood?
- Excuse me?
- How was your childhood?
- My childhood?
Well, the best way I can put it is,
I grew up in a violent neighborhood.
They had just about anything you wanted,
as far as drugs, liquor, whatever,
my surrounding was gang banging.
And you know, down here, life.
- [Mark] And you stayed at home
with your mom until how long?
- I stayed home with my mom
til I was about 12 years old.
I ran away from home.
I came downtown LA.
And I stayed downtown LA for
about three and a half years.
I went back home,
and got into a little trouble
but went to jail, juvenile hall.
Juvenile hall to a County jail,
from the County jail to prison.
- [Mark] Did you go to high school?
- Excuse me?
- Did you go to high school?
- I went to high school for three days.
And the reason why, the
neighborhood I stayed in,
was a gang,
whenever the gang was bounty hunters
from the Nickerson Gardens.
The school I went to was Jordan High,
and they had a project
called the Jordan Downs.
The Jordan Downs was cribbed,
and we was bloods.
And by me being a blood,
they kind of knew my face
and was like, hey, why shouldn't I,
I shouldn't Faisal,
my nickname was Faisal.
And they're like, ain't your name Faisal?
I'm like, yo.
They said, don't you sit
in Nickerson Gardens?
And before I can answer the question,
it was like almost the whole
school was coming towards me
which I knew was bad, so
I ran and I, like I said,
it was only for like three days.
I said, I can't go,
because I was in the wrong neighborhood.
The school was the wrong neighborhood.
And from there
I've been homeless still.
- [Mark] And drugs or
alcohol came in the picture
for you when?
- Alcohol, I was about
nine years old,
when I started drinking,
and what started me
drinking was my uncles,
my aunties used to always
come over to my mom house
and they used to play
cards, gamble, and drink.
My uncle, my favorite
uncle, he drunk one five
(yawns) excuse me.
He got Bacardi, Bacardi was like
one, five, one.
And usually people would
drink it back with Coke.
My uncle, he would drink it by itself.
He was my favorite uncle.
And one day he came over,
picked me up, took me with him.
And that's when I started drinking
with my uncle.
- [Mark] And at home with your mom,
she was into drugs or alcohol?
- Yes.
She was into drugs and alcohol.
And it would be times where she did have
what she wanted
and she would take it
out on me and my sister.
And I felt like she didn't care about me.
Why should I stay here?
And I ran away from home,
but drugs had a lot to do
with me running away too,
because I was like my mom
to a certain extent, you know,
and I can get what I want.
I would steal stuff, man, take
this stuff that didn't belong
to me and bring a problem to my house.
And the best way I knew how to get it
was to run away.
And they started me going to jail.
- [Mark] And what kind of
stuff were you getting into
at that point?
- Well, gang banging, females,
anything I could get into basically.
- [Mark] The prison time
you did was for what?
- Taking stuff from
somebody, stolen property,
breaking into houses, breaking into cars,
jacking people,
you know, all kinds of stupid stuff.
Now at that time it wasn't stupid,
because I was under an influence
and my mind
was basically,
I guess on one thing
and it was getting drugs
and I didn't have a job.
So it was only one way
I knew how to get it.
And that was, you know,
get somebody back there
and take from them.
- [Mark] Yeah, and that was crack cocaine
that you were chasing?
- That was, yes.
Yes.
- [Mark] And do you have kids of your own?
- No, I have no kids.
What really started me with
crack cocaine was my mom.
She was smoking.
(yawns) And I wanted to
see what it was like.
And I went and got some,
my mom had to choose,
so I brought it back to
her and she like looked
at me kind of crazy,
but she wanted some too.
So I started smoking with my
mom's and I was getting high
with my mom's for a long
time, until she passed away.
- [Mark] And how much prison
time have you done in all?
- The most prison time I've
done, was two and a half years.
- [Mark] But in total?
- Total, two and a half years.
- [Mark] Oh, so not that much prison time?
- No, it was basically in and
out because I was on parole.
Okay?
But me being on parole, when I got out,
it was certain things that I had to do.
I was still getting high,
so I didn't report
(yawns) because when I be put,
they would test me,
they would give me a drug
test and I know I'm dirty.
So it's like, I'm turning myself in, okay?
I felt like this at that time,
if I gotta be for it or turn myself in,
I'm not going to do it, okay?
Your job is either catch me
or I turn myself in and I
wasn't gonna turn myself in.
So anytime I got stuck, but
not in (indistinct), you know,
they would take me in.
That's the only way they would take me in,
and I got to be a violation of parole,
because I didn't report.
So they would take me back.
I had to go back to prison
for a certain amount of time.
Eight months, six months, you know.
- [Mark] And you've been
living on the street
for how long now?
(sighs)
- I'm 56.
I've been on the streets since I was 12.
- [Mark] And today you
are living in a tent?
- Yes.
- Down here on Skid Row?
Right down the street.
- [Mark] And what do you do for money now?
- I wash cars.
I wash windows.
I sweep, I do cleanup.
You know.
- You're still using crack?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Have you ever been clean?
- Only time I was clean
was when I got locked up.
- [Mark] Then you get out and
you eventually just go back?
- When I get out, my first
stop is the liquor store.
'Cause I mean, I really, really
like the drinking.
I like that feeling that
it gave me, you know,
and I just, it was something that I enjoy.
- [Mark] When you were
a child, did you have,
what kind of dreams did
you have for your life?
Did you, do you have any thing that you-
- I wanted to be, I wanted
to write, write books.
I like to write poem.
That's what I did, I started writing poems
when I was locked up.
Now I (indistinct).
Write the things that come to
my mind, things on my mind,
things I see in people,
other people, you know,
I like to move around like that.
- [Mark] Have you ever been in love?
- In love?
Yes, almost every female I've been,
really have been in
love (laughs), you know,
but it was just one particular
girl that I was in love,
I would do anything for her, anything.
If she asked me robbing
a bank, I probably would.
- [Mark] How do you think
outsiders as they drive
through Skid Row, what their
impression is of people,
that are living on the street like you do?
- Ooh, I don't know how to describe that.
I see
people that in their mind
call yourself pretty good,
and they look down on us,
on the people who lived on the streets.
And I met this one guy.
It was on the streets.
And about a week after
I was at the gas station with
a hustler and he drove up
to the gas station in a Mercedes, man,
this guy got a tent.
And he was like, you know what?
He say, only reason I was on the street,
I wanted to see what the
street life was about.
He said, man, I got two cars.
I got a wife, I got a family,
I got my own business.
And he said, here, the
guy handed me like $500,
to say, this for being my friend,
not looking down on me and not judging me.
And it kinda like, it
blew my mind, you know?
He said, yeah.
He says, I just want to see
what the street life was about.
Because a lot of people
look down on you guys,
and won't give you nothing
and they turn their nose up
when they will pass us.
And it hurts.
You know, I didn't go to school.
I went to school, but I
didn't go to the class.
You know?
And it's a big difference.
I don't look at myself no
different than anybody else.
I don't judge nobody.
You know,
it's an old saying, everything look good,
ain't always good, everything bad,
ain't also bad.
As bad as it looked, you know.
- [Mark] What do you think attracts people
to this street life?
I mean, the lack of
responsibility, you think,
and you never have to work,
you never have to pay taxes.
You never have to do anything.
- Well, but street to me,
street life is people,
that's into drugs.
Okay?
And just about everybody
that's on the streets is into something.
Okay?
Like where I'm living at right now.
I feel safer here.
I call this my home.
The reason why I call it my home
because it's my surrounding,
I feel better and safer here
than being around somebody,
work every day.
They don't drink.
It's a different feeling.
It's a different life.
So we call this home
because it's street life.
We do what we wanna do.
It's just different from
a person in Beverly Hills,
Hollywood, you know.
- [Mark] You feel like you belong here?
- Yes.
Because if, even though
I'm doing the same thing,
if I was standing in
Hollywood or Beverly Hills
I wouldn't feel right
because don't nobody,
ain't too many people up here
in Hollywood or Beverly Hills,
do a video.
They feel, but they went to
school, graduated, you know,
got jobs.
They're better than us.
And I wouldn't feel like, you know.
Here I don't have to hide
anything from anybody.
As far as you know what I do, you know.
I have to keep nothing from nobody
because everybody's doing the same thing,
is doing something in that area.
- [Mark] Do you think you'll be down here
for the rest of your life?
- Excuse me?
- You think
you'll be down here the rest of your life?
- I'm not, for sure
to a certain extent I'm not
really worried about it.
I used to think about
living and dying, okay?
And the more and more I
think about it, you know,
I think in my personal flow is,
we came here to do two things.
We came here to live and to die.
One day, it's not sure when we
gonna pass away or whatever,
but one day we all got to go.
So if it's my time to go,
ain't nothing gonna stop me from going,
because I became to live and die,
and it's gonna happen one way or another,
it is gonna happen.
And sometime I feel in my mind
yet, even if I do pass away,
I pass away to another world,
something different,
you know?
And I say, if it happened,
it happened, you know,
I hate to see people that's
close to me or anybody really
you know, pass away, you
know, but it's got to happen.
It's gonna happen.
I mean, it's going to, yes,
you can't get around it.
You can't get around
it, it's gonna happen.
So if you're getting
high or not getting high,
you die, you see, you're gone.
- [Mark] All right Edgar.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- No problem.
- Good luck with everything.
Thank you.
- Thank you.